I think that I realized that this is
gonna be trying for lunch reasons but
I'm trying to go quickly and I think the
good news is that I am nowhere near as
sophisticated as the various people who
have worked on the things that were
presented before this so the attention
that perhaps the perhaps that's good
news for getting to lunch a little
quicker okay so my motivation is really
to I'm sort of a one-trick pony I think
about tensor networks
I view everything in terms of that if I
can't see a good picture I give up and I
move on and so I have a picture and I
want to sort of share that picture and
then also in the process tell you how
that picture tells you something about
khatai of strong coin flipping bound so
this is work with Thomas and so I had
all kinds of plans to put fancy slide
here but then I decided I was had half
an hour and I was gonna embarrass
unknown people on the internet with
pictures of birthday party is that that
I didn't know so it didn't but anyway so
the strong coin flipping which we've
heard about already a bunch of times is
is worth me and garite when I flip a
coin and we really want it to be fair
alright we you know we don't quite know
what outcome each of us we're sort of
suspicious maybe each of us wants some
outcome that we don't know why but we
want it to be fair and so that's strong
coin flipping as opposed to weak claim
to thing and what does Qatar's result
say it says that you can't you know you
you can't do this perfectly right you
can only do this so if if what if we
have a strategy where if we both play it
honestly we could actually flip a coin
fairly then at least one of us can cheat
while the other one is doing fairly so
that we can buy us the corn in a
particular direction up to about the
square to exactly square root of 2 over
2 and this was proved originally by
qatayef and then a nice different proof
was given by the tuskegee and watch this
and the idea is here are sort of really
mimicking or sort of motivated by that
that stuff and this bound is as we've
heard multiple times this bound is tight
we can it actually achieve these
Thanks all right so okay so I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna tell you about a
different game and the word duel is used
but it's not the duel as an SDP duel and
I'm gonna it's a game of which I'm going
to show the kind of bias that katana
scoring flipping imply it is it same
same result as Qatar's I'm flipping in
terms of de bias and then then later on
I'm gonna show you why we can view coin
flipping as a duality game so the
duality game is rather simple which is
alice is constrained to play in some
play from some convex set of positive
matrices Bob is gets the play from the
dual set meaning the the set of positive
matrices for which this should say
somewhere in here it should have been
that the trace of B a is less than or
the one for all of Alice's choices and
the outcome of the game is when when one
person when Alice plays a and Bob place
being the outcome is the trace of it and
so suppose we have the situation where
we have and honest what we won is an
honest protocol which is that a play by
Alice and it played by Bob first the
outcome is a half all right let's say
that's the probability of coming up
heads okay so this is our set up suppose
we have this well then the result is
cheating can happen all right what do we
mean by that we mean that if Alice plays
honestly Bob can find a cheating
strategy or Bob if Bob plays on us
honestly Alice can find the cheating
strategy for which at least one of these
is bigger than the square root of two
over two and in fact what it it actually
says is that the product is greater than
equal to half which then it allows you
to bigger than square root of two and so
let me show you the picture of how this
proof works right so the blue is the set
of Alice's possible matrices all right
and Alice has this strategy right which
were on a strategy which sits there and
what do we know about Bob's on a
strategy right which is that there
the trace of the trace of their product
is going to be a half which I'm
depicting by a projection okay so it's a
picture it as though these are vectors
and this is an inner product the this is
this is our starting set up right so now
we ask how can Alice cheat well Alice
can cheat by trying to make that inner
product bigger right
and so here we see where we can go she
could go there right and if Alice cheats
and Bob stays the same okay then there's
some cheating probability that's at
least a half which we'll call P so this
would be this is telling us that this
number is Pete oh this was the this was
supposed to be the origin okay okay so
all right now we've designed Alice's
cheating strategy all right so now let's
just notice something here right the
biggest that Alice cheating strategy
could get was P right now bob has in his
repertoire anything for which the as
long as his strategy on the whole set is
less than or equal to one is okay so
actually Bob has a achieving strategy
that he has a strategy that he could
play
that's a scaled version of B zero that
makes this optimal point instead of
having a value P to have the optimal
point have a value one so that's what
I'm trying to depict here so I've drawn
a parallel line because I would want to
put it right on top of this one right
he's just his calibration of what what
the values are has changed is he scaled
up so his value is one which means now
since this value we've just scaled these
things we know what his value is on an
honest if he was to play this strategy
versus Alice's honest strategy he would
go for move from one a half to one over
two people yeah that's what strong coin
flip things I tell you what you you
don't want either per we don't know who
wants heads but but
we wanted to guard against the
possibility that one or the other of us
can influence it towards heads okay so
what do we got here so we've shown that
that there's a cheating strategy for Bob
that achieves one over to P a treating
strategy for Alice that you Chiefs P the
product is one-half Hey and that allows
us to conclude well rely because at
least one of them was bigger than
spiritual thank you for the beat for the
beat yes I can't so this is where we
stood right we found the optimal
treating strategy for Alice right and
the optimal opinion travesty for Alice
produced a value of P well in Bob's
repertoire is any scaled version of B
zero as long as on the whole convex set
their value is less than or equal to one
okay well if the biggest value can be P
that I can take in the repertoire
instead of b0 a scaled version of b0
that's you know in my dual thing and
what scale version doing can I use I can
use one over P times B zero because
that'll give my value to be one which is
the biggest that I'm allowed it to be
okay and then if I do that and I figure
out what happened this is just a scaled
version of the old one so it just scales
my value against a zero and it scaled it
from one half to one of it yeah we're
done we can go to lunch okay so the rest
of this talk is to convince you that in
fact what Alice and Bob are doing are
playing this kind of duality game so
what do we want how do we want to say
that Alice is playing from some convex
set containing zero positive operators
and Bob is playing and doing in coin
flipping okay okay sorry in coin
flipping that that's sorry in the coin
flip thing that's what's going on okay
so what that is equivalent to saying is
an understanding of this picture okay so
my motivation now is that have you
understand this picture which there's no
reason you should understand right the
moment just to give you a sense of
forever
okay so to do that I have to tell you
about tensors and penciler networks
which I'm gonna do pretty quickly so but
just by the way who can you just raise
your hand if you know tensor networks
marginally well okay so I'll tell you it
from my point of view how I think of it
and there are some conjugates and
various things that don't show up which
is fine you can ask me about and I'll
say don't worry about them but anyway so
what is a tensor a tensor for me is a
picture like this all right I have to
tell you how to understand this picture
so it's a picture with a node and a
bunch of edges coming out of it right
and each edge I'm gonna have some rules
for how this this picture each edge can
be labeled one of the different things
it's called the set 0 t minus 1 and this
is this this Emmylou this node comes
with the property that if i label every
edge by some of these any of these
labels out spits a number all right
sorry I've just given an example where I
instead of using numbers I colored them
different colors but imagine the yellow
was zero and the green was one and
cetera right so for any labeling of
these edges another number comes in so
it's just an array of numbers if you'd
like but I want to think of this array
of numbers in a bunch of different ways
and it's gonna be important that I think
about the noise and a bunch of different
ways so I can move from one way to
another visually not so to do so I'm
first I'm gonna start with a Hilbert
space just a finite dimensional hilbert
space it's D with a CD the dimensional
hilbert space and i'm gonna pick a
standard basis for it which is no
coincidence that I'm sort of course
modeling them to the labels and so then
one way I can interpret my M now is a
vector in a tensor product copy of H how
many copies of agent one for each edge
okay so in this case there are five
edges so I can view em as a vector in H
tensor together five times and how do I
view it I have to I'm going to just tell
you its coefficients and
the M is going to tell me its
coefficients on a basis what's the basis
for to tell you the coefficient for the
I one through I five basis element I'm
gonna spit out the number associated
with labeling the edges I won through I
fi and what is hidden here is a
correspondence between there's a choice
of these five and a choice of edges and
I have one copy of H assigned to each
edge so I arbitrarily say this is the
first this is the second copy of H third
fourth and fifth and so now I 1 I 2 I 3
8 4 5 so so ok so whenever I see a
picture associated to this picture is a
vector but that's not all there's also
going to be another Association I'm
going to freely move from those and
that's to interpret this tensor not as a
vector but as a linear map and now that
was one linear map but as a bunch of
linear maps so let me give you an
example of one of those linear maps I
can view it as a linear map from let's
say these three copies of H so tensor
EIJ three times to another Hilbert space
which is the tensor copy of H two times
and now to tell you a linear map I have
to tell you what the map is and so I'm
going to define it on a basis for this
Hilbert space right so to do so I have
to tell you what it's what it's so if
I've labeled this I 1 I 2 I 3 right
oh did I do it yeah oh I've done imagine
there's an i3 here but this I 3 over
there ok ok so I imagine I've labeled at
i1 i2 i3 and I want to so I want to say
I'm gonna tell you how I send that basis
element I'm gonna send it to a sum over
I 4s and i-5 and I tell you what what
the coefficient in front of each of the
i-4 is an i-5 says well with i1 i2 i3 in
the bag labeling the first guys and I
four and five on this side I've labeled
everybody so M is now a number again
there's a number associated because I've
labeled all the free edges and that's
the number I put in front now I could
have done that with any combination of
edges right I could have put some of the
edges in the front and some of the edges
in the back and so did I
all this different classes of maps and
this is basically the point of tensor
networks is it a single diagram has all
kinds of different interpretations as
linear maps going in different
directions so we'll see some examples so
now I want to tell you how to take these
so I've told you what this means right
this is an array of numbers I can think
of it as a map or as as a as a vector
I've told you what that means now I'm
going to tell you what a picture where
two of them are there okay so what is it
gonna be it's gonna be a new tensor so
I'm gonna imagine the blue imagine the
blue is one single blob that I kind of
shrink together and I've got now instead
of five edges or three edges coming out
of that one single blob
I now have eight edges right these five
and these three and to tell you what the
number so now and so with tensors this
is gonna be a new tensor but tensors as
soon as I label the edges on the round
the outside out should pop a number I'm
gonna tell you what number I'm gonna pop
out so you label the edges around the
outside okay and then I'm telling you a
number what is the number well each of
these different ends have been fully
labeled so they each have a number to it
associated to them and the number I
associate with this together is the
product of those two numbers okay so now
I can take tensors and I can put them if
I have individual ones I can stick them
on the same picture and I have a new
tensor out of that on a bigger space if
I want to think of it as a vector this
is now a vector on an eight copies of
eight that's the first thing I can do
with it and the second thing I can do is
contract which is to say once I have two
nodes I can join one of the edges to one
of the other edges and I want an
interpretation of that picture all right
so first of all it's gonna be a new
tensor with the number of edges
corresponding to the number of free
edges here right so again I'm gonna sort
of imagine that I put a red dotted line
around everything and I sort of
contracted that red dotted line into
this little thing and so I have to tell
you now if I label everything around the
outside here what the number I
associated with this is so I label
everything around the outside
okay now this guy is not labeled right
because he wasn't on the outside so I'm
gonna sum over all possible label names
of this guy so for any possible labeling
of this now I've got a picture for
everything's labeled so for any possible
labeling of this all these are labels
right for for any possible labeling in
this I have a number here a number here
at multiply those two numbers I get
together and then I sum over all
possible labels okay so this is maybe a
lot of mumbo-jumbo it maybe doesn't you
know it's hard to absorb very quickly if
you haven't seen it but let me just show
you give you a sort of feel for what
it's telling you and maybe you can do
that yourself which is I'm gonna draw
some pictures and we're gonna associate
these things to regular algebraic things
that we often do alright so M&P I ignore
the sort of I on the on the side so M&P
right we're two tensors which I joined
along an edge if I think about what that
means right it's the sum over that
labeling I of em I times P I and what is
that that's the inner product if I
thought of M and P as vectors what I've
written down there isn't now is now as a
number and the number turns out to be
the inner product of M and P and this is
the point where you say we should there
be a conjugate and I say don't worry
about the conjugates just think of
everything is real for them oh and
here's another example where m was a
bigger tensor and P was a bigger tensor
but if I think of that bigger B both of
those bigger tensors as vectors and I
and then this picture is the inner
product okay now I'm gonna draw a second
picture here's a second picture of a
combination of an M&M P and in this case
M right it was sort of a vector with two
things coming out of it and I'm gonna
think of that M as a linear map from the
top edge to the bottom edge so it's a
matrix okay and P is gonna be a linear
map from here to here and if I actually
do the calculation of what this ends up
being the sense of being matrix product
and so here's a picture honest-to-god
matrix product there's nothing design
you know it really is the matrix product
you sum over J
my J times pJK that's what he did and
traces this picture so if I again if I
have the matrix M Weber if the tensor M
but I think of it as a matrix from here
to here if I loop them around back to
themselves and I compute what it comes
out of this this is the sum over the
labelings this is a label I this guy
gets them to label by M I I these are
the some of the diagnosis is okay so now
we have sort of fully in Scots were
ready to go and let me just have some
minor adjustments the first minor
adjustment is before I told you that
every Edge has the same labeling set now
I'm gonna tell you we're gonna allow I
just to be have different labeling sets
and I just make sure when I join two
edges the edges that I am joining have
the same labeling set so that
corresponds to having some Humbert
spaces the different sizes than other
Hilbert space and the second thing I'm
going to do is instead of using dots I'm
going to use boxes because boxes often
remilia to people who do circuits and so
you know a circuit is a matrix and so we
can think of it you know there are many
different ways to think of this matrix
or this this tensor as I've said but you
know we can think of it as a map from
here to here and so now let's take a
look at the coin flipping Network and
what it looks like so what do I do is
Alice and Bob first start out with an
initial initial eyes state right so what
is their initialized state what we you
know I can write it as a tensor like
that that's a vector right so here are
two vectors one analysis side one and
Bob side bob applies some unitary gate
okay and then sends part of its
operating space over to Alice right or
maybe you think of this as the channel
that they're communicating on and then
Alice apply something and sends their
thing we're back over to Bob Bob apply
something we continue this for a while
okay and in the wind so maybe there are
a bunch of more different things in the
end okay and here's the sort of a
distinction to make in the end we make a
measurement and let's get right down the
the chance that both people measure
heads okay both people's outcome
measures heads so what does that mean
that means that actually what happened
here was a projection onto the
projective part of the measurement that
was head so this is a projection
operator and this is a projection
operator and what we have left is this
decomposition of this is the vector
right there would be in the sub space
that for which the outcome just before
you do the measurement was going to be
ahead right okay so they here this is a
vector so let's take a look at this this
is a vector where does it sit well it's
you know there are a lot of closed edges
here these are the only three open edges
so it's a state so back and we'll think
of it as a vector right now and the
vector that it is is the component of
upon which you know heads is gonna be
the outcome so the probability of
getting heads is exactly the norm square
root of this vector okay so here's a
vector the norm squared of this vector
is the probability of getting heads so
how do I get the norm squared out of a
vector well what do I do a inner product
with itself right so I get the norm
squared I have a picture for inner
product with itself what do I have to do
I just have to join this guy to itself I
have to promote a second copy of it and
stick it together just like inner
product right so I do that by flipping
it over and joining it to itself and now
there's sort of a small salty which is
if I was to these bees have turned
upside down which means they're the the
U stars so you're familiar with this a
lot of you are familiar with this in
other ways but here's the picture this
is a number right honest to God number
where does it represent represents the
probability of the protocol coming out
heads all right so here's an out of the
plane take that and isolate the stuff
that Bob can do and the stuff that Alice
can do the blue separates what Alice's
analysis Alice has complete control over
what they're doing on that side Bob has
complete control over doing what's on
the other side and the constraints they
have is they have to play unit Aires or
partial isometry Xin here and they have
to play projection in there and now if
you take Alice's part and separate it
and Bob's part and separated how can I
interpret
pictured differently from when I was
pitching it before the left side is some
tensor the right side is some cancer and
we're screwing them together which is
inner product okay so what we can see
this is this is a game where Alice picks
from their choice of vectors Bob picks
from their choice of vectors and they
play their inner product that's the
outcome baby so remember what our plan
was
right our plan was to show that Alice is
set of strategies somehow sits in some
convex set and then Bob strategies are
the dual and then we're in a then we're
in a duality game as it was home and
we're done so how do we do that well we
just take this blue picture okay and
what I'm gonna do is you know what goes
on here the mirror of it is coming down
here right and so I'm just gonna Bend
these two pieces to the side just to
look at them in a different way and what
I'm gonna look at them as a map from
these input edges those guys on the top
to the output edges on the bottom so
that becomes this picture here okay so
does everybody see sort of if you take
the blue and you sort of stretch it back
out that way you had what you had before
but now I'm really thinking of it as a
map from the top to the bottom it's
clearly a matrix I mean I'm thinking of
it as a matrix it's positive because
there's a correspondence between these
guys and these guys and you can sort of
realize that you realize if you think
about it for a minute that it's
something times its star that you're
multiplying by so all these are positive
and similarly for for Bob I did the same
thing I took Bob's thing let's see what
did i do exactly to it I guess I took
the bottom part and I sort of bended it
upwards and I took the top part and slid
it around downwards
all right and so to get the action so
another way to glue these things
together is to multiply these two
matrices together and joining them up
there and then taking the trace which
what is taking the trace means it means
joining this guy around to that guy and
the rest of the guys and if you sort of
follow that through you'll see you'll
get you get right back to this picture
okay so what so okay so what's true of
these collections have been so now we've
isolated the spaces on which Alice and
Bob can play and what's what's the set
of strategist well as matrices I
mentioned they're positive
they contain zero you can sort of see
that pretty clearly by just sticking in
a projection zero here and make the
whole thing zero they're convex that's
not very hard to show MIT doesn't allow
you to have lunch in as much time as you
would otherwise but it's pretty short
and the thing that is very cool is the
fact that these are dual spaces and this
is this is a the Watchers kotovsky is
sort of how they showed that these two
spaces were dual and it's a sort of nice
inductive argument when you strip down
all the all the pieces it's really sort
of quite pleasant okay and so we have
our duality all right so now we go back
to our duality argument and we're done
okay
so now the thing is when I agreed to
give this when it went it was organized
to give this talk I had the dream that
this would be a better presentation that
it is because there are certain things
that are missing and these are the best
things that are meant these are the
biggest pieces that are missing right
how do we see the best play for Alice
given Bob's play in pictures okay so
sorry there okay so imagine fixing Bob
right there's some best play for Alice
it shouldn't be that hard to see what it
is but I don't know what it is and the
second is even it sort of maybe even
easier question which is remember how
that duality the original duality
argument why it was very simple it
didn't require
here okay everything up we didn't
require full duality right all we were
required was you know here's B zero
which is where we're starting
we just need to guarantee that this guy
is in B right I'm glad we do it we use
duality to do it we said hey look this
guy is doesn't do so badly so but really
it's just a scaled version of the old
guy right so what happened it shouldn't
require you to just have to put this big
hammer on to say that you need duality
you should be able to see that the
scaled up version is still a valid play
for Bob and that was the thing that sort
of kept me not preparing the talk
because I thought as soon as I get that
I could make a talk that lasted 10
minutes and we could get out of here
so I sort of I would like to know I
don't we I don't either that's part of
the reason why I wanted to sort of put
it out there is is the thing now if you
wanted a protocol where there I guess
one comment to make is if you want to
view a protocol where people could start
with some entanglement before you start
okay that actually just changes the
picture by saying instead of starting
with product states you can start with
something in tango but you can just sort
of depict by a line going from one to
other and sticking a tensor up the top
but I think all these I really do think
of thinking about it this way is helpful
John and Gus have the paper that doesn't
do it intentionally for picture which is
meeting with the came up with a phrase
it algebraically this duality and that
that works for we have a very general
statement yeah so so the duality gave
our lied that both people were pushing
in the same direction right so you're
sort of just saying look you know one
person wants heads and the other person
is willing to give them heads that's so
it's really that's the it's plugging it
into the duality game